good morning Hank it's Wednesday I'm at
my in-laws house like most of the
internet I am fascinated by honey
badgers these 2 to 3 foot long creatures
that weighed 30 pounds live here eat
anything and weed these solitary
non-monogamous lives of total badassery
but Hank Randall's famous and crazy ass
narration does nothing to capture the
glory of the honey badger
dum-dum-dum honey badger her Hank I'm
not making this up although it's hotly
debated among naturalist but there are
lots of reports of honey badgers which
are small attacking larger prey like
wildebeests or zebras or water buffalo
by going straight for the nuts this is
known as emasculating your prey
basically you just bite off the balls
and then you attack the rest although
there are many reports that when honey
badgers attack humans which does happen
occasionally they do go straight for the
nuts dum dum dum dum honey badger hang a
lot of biologists believe that honey
badgers are able to attack beehives
because they go up to those beehives and
then release sent out of their anal
glands which is so mallow Duras that the
bees run away and then the honey badgers
are able to take the honey that's right
Hank
they use a fart attack so not only do
honey badgers have like the most
fearsome claws and teeth in the animal
kingdom they also have the stinkiest
farts of course some bees are ugly stay
behind and sting honey badgers but it
doesn't bother them much because they
are more immune to bee venom than almost
any mammal on the planet dum dum dum dum
honey badger so Hank you know a cheetah
cubs look like probably not because you
probably didn't spend your entire
Thanksgiving vacation researching honey
badgers they look like this and many
wildlife biologists speculate this is an
evolutionary adaptation to make baby
cheetahs look like honey badgers because
no predator would ever want to attack a
honey badger unless it's absolutely
desperate because honey badgers are
harder to kill the 19th century Russian
monks what--it's Rasputin joke it's too
obscure come on everybody knows rescue
ting dum dum dum dum honey badger let's
tackle the question of why honey badgers
are so hard to kill so honey badgers
like an Olsen twin have more skinned and
seems entirely necessary given their
frame this loose skin this means that
whenever you grab or bite them there's
always room for them to like come around
and bite you back plus their skin is
incredibly thick like you can't hack
through it with a machete and it's
resistant to arrows it's like some kind
of super skin so here you are trying to
bite through this super skin creature
and he's coming around and bite
your face and you're just thinking I
should have gotten a ghazal dum dum dum
dum honey badger her so all this means
that the number one honey badger
predator like most animals is humans
selling about your skin and again I'm
not making any of this up can stop some
bullets but you can kill them with a
high-powered rifle but they get us back
because they often dig up human graves
and eat our ancestors sum dum dum dum
honey badger her honey badgers Hank they
are not kidding around so that's what I
did with my Thanksgiving vacation I also
watched a lot of tape of myself playing
Fifa to prepare for the FA Cup final
we're going back to the FA Cup final the
Swindon Town sweet Olli poopers will be
facing Chelsea Football Club and we will
avenge our terrible loss in last year's
FA Cup final and I am excited if you
don't know what I'm talking about link
in the doobly-doo Hank I hope you
learned something about honey badgers I
will see you on Friday